condensed matter physics is the study of
matter and the diverse forms of matter
that arise when atoms and electrons are
assembled in different ways
it's the most active field of
contemporary physics and has yielded
some of the biggest breakthroughs of the
past century but as rapidly as
technology has advanced scientists have
only scratched the surface of the
electrons potential harnessing just a
few of its behaviors
now for the first time ever a married
couple of physicists at cornell have
figured out a way to create artificial
atoms in the lab opening the door to a
new era of research in this field of
physics called condensed metaphysics is
basically about the properties of
behavior of
trillions of trillions electrons i'm
just curious you know about something i
don't understand both sides you and phi
they're pioneers by and g
live
more or less completely devoted to
physics
we are good at different things i think
that that actually makes us a good team
[Music]
electrons are the animating actors of
the material world yet their behavior
remains elusive
they can tunnel
orbit
spin
and behave in other mysterious ways
making them notoriously difficult to
study especially in large groups
to understand and manipulate the
dynamics of many electrons together g
shan and phi mac have had to get
creative in their lab at cornell we try
to
deal with electrons in a more
controllable way and try to explore the
quantum nature of electrons more after a
decade of patient and steady work shan
and mack have developed an experimental
setup that is as surprising as it is
groundbreaking
so the problem is so
complicated that you just really want to
capture this essential of interacting
electrons and they are jiggling around
randomly so you want to look at this
problem in its simplest way one way to
simplify experimental conditions is to
use what are called 2d materials sheets
of metal a few atoms thick 2d materials
are an excellent platform to control and
also understand the behavior of
electrons two-dimensional materials are
great because we are not two-dimensional
we are three-dimensional so
that is just really convenient because
you can look at it from the top and you
can push on it with electric fields or
you can put magnetic fields on it and
then you can look and see what happens a
popular choice of 2d material is
graphene the building block of graphite
and the thinnest material known to
scientists as an ideal conductor
electricity passes through graphene with
minimal resistance but its conductivity
is difficult to control once an
electrical current starts flowing
scientists can't turn it off
in search of more control shannon mack
turn to alternative 2d materials known
as semiconductors
you can control the number of electrons
in those systems
really precisely when you don't want the
current you can turn off the current and
then you can make a transistor out of
this so what we actually find is
basically a semiconductor that is just
a few atoms thick
this platform they've been working on
based on the semiconductor it's kind of
interesting playground to construct
their tiny playground to study the
atomic world the researchers developed a
method to isolate sheets of
semiconducting metals known as tmds
short for transition metal to
calcagenides each one just a few atoms
thick
they meticulously stack the metal flakes
on top of each other and the slight
structural differences create a
repeating pattern known as a moire super
lattice
this idea of moire superlatis
really opens a new
kind of
avenue in a series of landmark papers
the researchers have used their tightly
controlled stack of semiconductor sheets
to explore various exotic quantum
phenomena this material that they've
made just sort of shows all of this
textbook physics
plus surprises all
all in one system
perhaps the most significant
breakthrough of all came when the
researchers demonstrated the ability to
simulate the behavior of artificial
atoms
by harnessing an electromagnetic
attraction between the overlaid sheets
in their stack the researchers can
create simulated atoms 100 times the
size of real atoms allowing for far
greater experimental control
and then by turning a knob the
researchers can adjust the voltage
probe the system with this laser and
change the properties of their
artificial atoms in a new form of
scientific alchemy when we change the
number of electrons in each atom it's
like a changing one element to another
element right if you put one electron
into the atom you create like an
artificial hydrogen atom and if you put
two electrons into the atom you create
artificial helium atom if you put three
electrons you create artificial lithium
atom by just controlling the voltage we
are controlling the filling of the
electron in each atom one two three and
every time we do it we change the
chemistry so that in this case is really
a game changer because now we can
actually sort of design chemistry or
design artificial material
just by stacking this material and
applying voltages
to just how to to tame the electrons
shannon mack have used their moire
system to coax electrons into realizing
a series of unusual states of matter
including mott insulators wigner
crystals
and churn insulators
with potential applications to quantum
computing energy storage and other next
generation technologies the sort of
beautiful successes have in some ways
come from realizing
a really elegant
physical system it's that compromise
between having a lot of experimental
control understanding how it relates to
something that you understand well
theoretically but having enough tunable
parameters where you can still be
surprised
insights gained from a tiny stack of
semiconductor flakes may one day reveal
secrets that will power a future era of
superconductors a holy grail of
technology the marine materials
themselves may not have high enough
critical temperature to be used for
superconductor in any near future but
the principles that we can learn from
them
may actually help us to understand the
principles and therefore design
superconductors that have higher
transition temperature or critical
temperatures in the future it would be
great to be able to transmit electricity
for long distances without any
dissipation that would you know that
would have a huge technological impact
on a very basic part of our energy
infrastructure this is
an amazing moment you know
in my life and my students life
many phenomena
have been
observed but i think many more are
coming
so i i think this is just the beginning
of it
[Music]
you